Hunter do you have a day job outside of
filmmaking I actually do not have a day
job and it's taken me a while to get to
this point where I think for the last
two now three years I've not had a day
job but I think about day jobs sometimes
I definitely have those moments where
I'm like well maybe I'll go back and dip
in and take some easy cash for a little
while but not at this point I don't at
what moments do you entertain that idea
it depends I mean it's definitely
moments of frustration when you know you
you work very hard to raise a bunch of
money for Walter for example and you
know we did a crowdfunding campaign we
raised $25,000 and and we spent it all
very fast you know it's basically
accounted for but it was sort of our
strategy with how we're gonna release
this film and once you put that money
back out there into the system
you definitely have these moments where
you're like gosh it's just too easy to
spend this money and you know we're
we're you know looking at how long it'll
take for the money to start coming back
it's a calculated sort of gamble that
would that we face but you have these
moments where you go through the process
and you see what the industry is really
like and you see how much competition is
out there and how much content is out
there and you're like hmm is it really
worth all this energy that we're not
only that we're contributing but now
that others through crowd you know
crowdfunding and and you know a fan base
is supporting to really you know keep
keep after it you know for what what you
get in return so you know you have those
moments that just creep up on you and
then something inevitably happens where
you calm down and you know you something
something comes your way and all of a
sudden you're like gosh you sit down a
lot of times it's sitting down and
seeing an audience watch your film and
feeling it really have the effect that
it's supposed to or you get this
wonderful
email or a conversation that you had
with somebody that sort of turns you
back around and makes you
realize it's like this is for whatever
reason this is what I was put on this
this earth to do and I gotta keep making
these films so we have now five films
under your belt
at what point of those five films were
you able to walk away from a day job so
I have five films of directed and
there's been another one I produced with
Mike Dion called reveal the path and it
was about the time that Mike and I came
together on ride the divide that I was I
was actually thinking I was done for
sure and I was working a day job and or
I was getting ready to work in a job I
was kind of shifting things up and so I
I shot this film with Mike ride the
divide and I was like okay this may be
my last hoorah you know get out there
this was number three
number two was a total bomb and I was
like I'll go shoot this enjoy this
moment and then go work and you know
work the agency life and see where it
takes me but I remember stepping into
that agency life and that kind of put
one foot in and kept the one foot out
and I was like I really don't want to
work full-time so I set up a nice social
structure where I was essentially
working full time but I was contract
position and it it's still that time
though where I figured you know this is
probably going to be the way it goes but
over time as ride the divide came out
and was released
you know we saw quite a bit of success
with that film and that was about the
time where I think I felt that you know
I got to just get out there again and
give it another go that was probably it
really wasn't until we saw that film
take off but I had that feeling that I
could I could do this full-time but I
realized that if I do it full-time
I have to do it full-time and more than
full-time you know what makers will work
in every hour we can trying to get this
this content made looking good and then
ultimately distributed them and marketed
so you know you still have to check in
every once long ago okay breathing
there's actual money coming in from the
titles that I made in the past you know
we're figuring out a system to do this
but it's it's not easy it's not easy
much
for sure and it's usually just enough to
kind of get by and you're kind of
funding all the way as you can to to
continue shortcutting so fortunately it
took that one one title that ride the
divide that kind of gave gave us you
know gave me enough sort of confidence
in myself but also you know a little bit
of cash flow and then and then you know
being smart about my next few titles and
not overspending and finding ways to
make sure they get to market and that
they you know also continue to give a
little bit of revenue stream to to our
to my approach I find the cash flow is
like instant confidence yeah it really
is so what would you advise to another
filmmaker who has probably lived that
40-hour week life as most of us have at
one time and training themselves I know
we talked about it briefly because it
seems like it if I remember correctly
from some videos I watched you were
close to going back before you did
Walter yeah yeah for sure I mean it's
you have to keep questioning you know
why you're doing this is it worth it is
is that are the sacrifices you make
unfortunately the the corporate world
that you see around you that so many of
your friends are are investing in you
know and getting return for you know is
is tempting at times just because you
see people living this life where they
get things and they buy things they
consume you know but that's not
necessarily the right lifestyle for
everybody that's certainly not going to
guarantee happiness it's not gonna you
know fulfill you if you're somebody who
needs to be creative and needs to tell
stories and has these thoughts that you
feel are important for the time and
that's and if you if you ignore those if
you're one of those people and you're
ignoring that you ultimately you know
dip into that corporate system you know
it's not you know it's not necessarily
going to to deliver that happiness so I
think I got off track I'm I'm uh you
know trying to try to remember the exact
question but ultimately oh no no I think
that's though it's a great point that
you did talk about because maybe
do need to kind of be able to buy what
they need to buy and I realize like okay
I'm kind of bored now this is not I
don't know if I want to turn my life
over for this many hours yeah just so I
can buy stuff yeah but I think the
initial question I had was oh how would
you change or how would you train
someone or not train them but advise
them from making that shift because it's
one thing to like say oh I'm gonna cut
back I'm gonna cut out cable I'm gonna
not go to Starbucks and things like that
but there's some drastic mindset changes
I think you have to make right it's it's
not just going without the morning latte
I think you have to you trust in things
yeah for sure I think if you really want
to make films you have to realize that
you're going to give a lot to that and
you're going to put a ton of time and
probably have to cut a lot of things out
of your life and at some point you'll
get lucky and at some point you know
you'll work hard enough that the return
will start to come for me it's a matter
of it I look at film is a long-term
investment I think most people look at
it as a short-term investment it's not
your first project it shouldn't you know
you're not likely to have that one-hit
wonder
and take off and totally have this
career that said that it's extremely
unlikely and it and it's something that
we should be all dreaming about dreaming
about and it will happen to a few but
for most of us it's going to be
something that we really need to take a
lot of time with and find a way to have
a lifestyle that allows you to keep
producing films for some people that is
the day job and for me it was at times
and I never discount it it may be again
there may be a point where I say I need
to go back and and work a day job for a
little while and just have that
experience and that my my mind rest from
having to always you know compensate
make it happen
you